i know you wish today was different
if i could change it you know i would
listen i let you know a little secret
nothing can keep you from feeling good
yeah it's all the way you see it
everything will be great when life gives
you
gonna be lemonade
[Music]
is
hey check it out the library we can play
hide and seek in the kids corner
or you could keep jeeping your head
across the sidewalk like a sad vacuum
cleaner
i choose sad vacuum cleaner don't worry
mailman you'll feel better soon
i don't want to feel better i want to
sit here and feel
sad forever forever
is a long time but when forever is over
we'll be waiting for you inside can we
go to the pop-up book section
huh what it's the best section hmm
is that a pop-up fire truck book no
no no no i can't have fun on my worst
day ever
why is this happening to me
melvin you're here you decided to make
the best of the damn play with us
no i just didn't want to sit in the rain
i'll keep having my worst day ever
right here what is it
is that the book version of good luck
truck now we can all find out how the
movie ends
this is awesome this is awful what do
you mean
none of us know how to read oh right
there is that there has to be a way to
turn things around
attention kids corner story time starts
in
15 minutes in the reading nook today's
book
is luigi the leprechaun story time
all we have to do is get the librarian
to read good luck truck for story time
and we'll all get to hear the ending but
she's not reading good luck truck she's
reading luigi the leprechaun
not if we perform a little book swap
thanks for trying
but i think i'll just go watch the rain
is he gonna be okay i hope so alex